[Musica]
bene c'è mai stata nella vostra infanzia
durante la vostra vita un personaggio
dei cartoni animati che riusciva sempre
a ribaltare la situazione
no no candy candy no per favore basta
essere un po più la persona il
personaggio che io ho adorato durante la
mia infanzia
era lei pippi calzelunghe
sì perché pp facciamo una cosa
particolare quando le cose non
funzionavano come lei voleva o comunque
quando le cose si mettevano un po male
lei faceva una cosa con il corpo saliva
su un albero si metteva testa in giù e
guardava alle cose controverso perché
questo perché pp
era un personaggio che creava
costantemente il gioco allora guardiamo
un po questo personaggio
vediamo un po se gli psicologi mi danno
retta pp non aveva una mamma sindrome da
abbandono pb
niente il padre scomparso cercare tesori
per mare sindrome da abbandono quindi un
disastro pp era una bambina tristissima
però no no
pp riusciva a cambiare sempre il punto
di vista degli altri riusciva sempre a
trasformare la situazione da tragedia a
gioco questo mi ha entusiasmata e
durante l'infanzia
mi ricordo che ogni volta
nelle situazioni difficili c'era la sua
vocina che mi diceva ti portiamo le cose
da un altro verso mettiamolo in un altro
modo ma io adesso in giù vedrei come
diventa tutto molto ironico e così
facevo e questa modalità questa ricerca
è continuata poi in avanti durante
l'adolescenza ei miei genitori mi
chiamavano sempre signorina no bastian
contrario io dovevo fare le cose a modo
mio
natascha trovati il fidanzato studia
lavora fa è tutto come quello che ti
diciamo noi la risposta era no
esattamente esattamente esattamente
perché gli adulti da bambina mi
sembravano tutti come gli uomini grigi
di mom tutti uguali tutti standardizzati
tutti i noiosi non avevo voglia di
diventare un fossile sinceramente e
quindi ho cominciato a fare le cose
chiaramente a modo mio e non è stato
facile anzi vi dirò di più è stato molto
molto molto più difficile perché non c'è
una mappa non c'è la mappa c'è solamente
la ricerca la ricerca di un'identità la
ricerca faticosa di un identità e non è
stato sempre facile andare alla ricerca
della propria identità
solo che era una spinta una spinta
troppo forte non riusciva a soffocarla
non riusciva a fermarla c'era qualcosa
che ogni volta mi faceva dire le cose le
devi fare a modo tuo
devi andare alla ricerca del tuo perché
della tua identità della tua sensibilità
e lo devi fare attraverso il corpo la
testa si fa un sacco di viaggi vai nel
corpo cosa succede nel corpo cosa senti
nel corpo quella è la verità non era
facilissimo perché poi chiaramente piano
piano come questo cerchietto qua
pazzo era stretto questo non puoi questo
non devi questo non sei in grado questo
6 inadeguata e che insomma no basta o
cosa succedeva che finalmente è arrivata
l'adolescenza bene periodo dei filosofi
dei maestri della ricerca ancora più
vorace quale sarà la verità
e poi è scappato fuori uno che diceva
conosci te stesso è esattamente la
risposta che mi serviva conosci te
stesso si ok va bene come faccio a
conoscere me stessa come faccio con
questa continua ribellione interna che
si muove dentro di me
poi un giorno trovo questa frase il
ribelle vive libero dagli schemi del
passato
ban folgorazione
non c'è stato più contenimento rompere
gli schemi rompere tutto quello che mi
era stato scritto detto raccontato di me
no di loro io ho cominciato a rompere le
catene a buttare via le maschere e non è
stato semplice no è stato ancora più
difficile perché andare alla ricerca
della propria identità e un viaggio
difficile da percorrere un viaggio di
fede nei confronti di ciò che mi anima
va dentro il desiderio ardeva il fuoco
ardeva spegne del fuoco che arde
impossibile
impossibile e quel fuoco continua ad
ardere e quel fuoco continuava ad
animarli e quel senso di viaggio di
ricerca continua va sempre di più ma
perché mi chiedevo ma perché perché
tutto questo ardore perché tutta questa
fame di identità e non l'avevo ancora
mica capito
mi ricordo un giorno in particolare
forse uno dei più difficili in assoluto
nella ricerca di questa identità stavo
correndo sulla spiaggia fatica è il
giorno difficilissimo cadeau sulla
spiaggia sbatto la faccia contro la
terra in quel momento lì quando tutto
veramente mi sembrava completamente
perso completamente finito e mi stavo
dicendo forse ho davvero sbagliato tutto
forse avrei dovuto seguire le regole
forse avrei dovuto stare nei canoni
forse avrei dovuto rimanere nel
quadratino in quel momento lì quando
stavo per arrendermi una voce ha gridato
dentro di me
natasha alzati alzati vai
questo è il tuo cammino questa è la tua
missione se non ti alzi adesso fuori per
sempre
alzati vai rimettiti a correre e porta
tutto questo in giro per il mondo
se sono qua forse mi sono rialzata voi
cosa dite
[Applauso]
quello che mi ha mosso profondamente in
quel momento lì si chiama fede fiducia
verso un qualcosa che veramente non
sapevo cosa fosse ma era molto forte
la fede nei confronti di un desiderio
avete mai sentito la forza dentro di voi
una forza incredibile un desiderio forte
qualcosa che veramente vi brucia dentro
qualcosa che ogni giorno vi fa guardare
allo specchio e dire ok ok ci sei anche
oggi hardy anche oggi vi hanno detto che
non potevate cercano di spegnerli quella
fiammella cercano di spegnere il
desiderio ma voi nel corpo lo sentite e
se lo sentite nel corpo
ricordatevi che nessuno ve lo può
spegnere e io ha voglia di fare un gioco
in questo momento con voi chi ha voglia
di giocare con me grandi allora vedete
questa immagine ci sono due ragazzi gli
yeah e che spingono controverso
vi chiedo di fare la stessa cosa
giratevi verso la persona che avete di
fianco mettete le mani appoggiate
bravissimi fantastico
ora c'è alessandro carrozza che lo fa
con maiali si affronta non capita tutti
i giorni
no ok ragazzi momento importantissimo
chiudete gli occhi
pensate al vostro desiderio più profondo
state nella pancia ascoltatelo nel cuore
sentite forte quel desiderio sentite
tutte le volte che vi hanno detto non
può non esiste non sei in grado non si è
adeguato e adesso con le vostre mani
spingete controverso io ce la posso fare
io sono libero di vivere la mia vita io
sono libero di costruire tutti i miei
desideri ascoltate cosa sta succedendo
nel vostro corpo quale spinta vi muove
quale passione vi muove quale ardore vi
sta infuocando il corpo ascoltate che
cosa succede lasciate andare le mani
ascoltate il corpo che cosa è successo
che cosa è successo dentro di voi che
cosa hanno sentito le vostre mani per un
attimo forza passione grinta
forse commozione
ecco questo è fuoco questo è fede se
volete realizzare i vostri sogni
sarà sicuramente una sfida andare
controverso certo però vi assicuro che
se non andate controverso e dimenticato
i vostri sogni
dormite tutta la vita e forse troppo
tardi quindi anche a costo di andare
contro verso seguite i vostri sogni
perché sono veramente sacri
[Applauso]
[Musica]